alors parmi nous ce soir un philosophe
ce qui m'a inspiré un constat assez
profond enfin quand on voit la situation
en grèce on se dit que c'est normal que
ce soit le pays qui a inventé la philo
ben oui quand on n'a pas les moyens de
s'en sortir autant avoir les outils pour
relativiser son échec
qu'est ce que la philo le christianisme
des athées gaspard proust humoriste haut
de gamme on passe à la suivante la
fameuse photo d'arnaud montebourg a fait
la semaine moi j'ai pas très bien
compris quoi c'est quoi c'est encore une
pub pour le mariage gay
on m'a expliqué que c'est censé
représenter la france qui réussit une
marinière un mixeur
arnaud montebourg le mannequin des vide
greniers du 11e arrondissement
ok ils montrèrent de la soi-disant de
luxe une montre de luxe avec un nom de
camembert ou de biscottes
comme si les allemands faisait des
voitures haut de gamme avec des prénoms
de concierge espagnol
s'ils voulaient vraiment marquer le coup
ils auraient mieux fait de poser en
costume dior bottines berluti dans un
rafale avec une escalope de foie gras
posé sur la gauche
heureusement que sa copine porte des
lunettes à 15000 euros et on a au moins
un pour rattraper l'autre
façon politiquement il n'y a rien à dire
que je veux dire hollande impérial de
gouvernance héros incandescente charisme
valls unique voulez du gouvernement
laure moysset suffit hollande bashing
moi je vais pas le critiquer plus ça
passe plus je le trouve sympa quoi pour
une fois qui est un type qui met un peu
de poésie dans la politique quand je le
voyais fait penser à un personnage de
jacques tati faisant du pédalo au mieux
du cap horn
il manque un truc sur le portrait
officiel du président cissé magritte qui
avait fait il aurait écrit ceci n'est
pas un président
et puis et puis jean marc ayrault pareil
quand enfin il a pris son autonomie
plus besoin de ses ministres pour
cafouillé c'est un génie en poster
keaton du texte législatif foutu
d'avancé et le type il vient à la radio
pour dire oh on a fait un texte mais
passera pas
vraiment un humour que le type il a de
la peine à recadrer ses ministres il
annonce une opération pour pacifier la
corse ouais
ben voyante le chef des logis jean marc
qui lancent l'opération tempête du
maquis
résultat deux jours plus tard nouveaux
morts sur l'île
à mon avis le corse il est mort de rire
quand en apprenant ces héros qui allait
perdre et quoi
alors ça ça ne s'est pas su c'est normal
c'est la tradition en corse par renard
on a criblé son corps de balles en corse
une mort naturelle c'est jusqu'à trois
balles
entre 4 et 8 c'est un différend
économique au delà de 8 c'est une bavure
de chasse
ça c'est bon pour moi et un truc dans ce
gouvernement il ya du désir il ya du
désir najat vallaud-belkacem
ah ouais non
comment résister à son air d'écolière
ingénue qui semblent dissimuler derrière
son pupitre des socquettes blanches à
pompon est sous sa jupe une culotte bio
c'est à dire rien
pour moi elle représente la synthèse
idéale de deux choses a priori
impossible la volupté pédophile sans le
risque de l'âge
sur la prochaine fois que je la croise
moi j'attaque direct
alors ça se passe bien en cm2
chez moi on va faire un atelier pâte à
modeler
pardon c'est un gouvernement qui semble
obsédé par le cul mais sans rien y
connaître franchement ils ont cette idée
de rembourser la pilule des quinze ans
il y avait une mesure beaucoup plus
simple et moins coûteuse encourager la
sodomie
non mais
les encourager par non mais la sodomie
c'est quand même un beau geste de mixité
sociale
la volupté du riche la contraception du
pauvre
et puis la gauche est faible évidemment
plus ça aiguise les appétits alors
borloo a décidé de créer lui dit rien
que le sigle moi j'ai pas envie d'y
aller enfin gea côté os ou st lô c'est
plus sexy
mais quand tu vois les parages giscard
simone devait l'emmener en 2012 il
on est en 2012 il convoque les trente
glorieuses face et qui va faire la
bande-son de clips de campagne vladimir
cosma
un peu de compassion chrétienne même
vous pelletier franchement vous toute
façon si vous avez fait des conneries
fin faut arrêter le rapport merapi
constate que la des séries a sous-estimé
le risque c'est vrai quand on lit le
rapport y avait pas de quoi s'inquiéter
recel d'armes goût pour les scream
frères salafistes visionnage de casser
de l'exécution intérêt prononcé pour les
tribus pakistanaise voyage de six mois
en afghanistan
tu lis le rapport tu dit ce mec c'est
pas un terroriste et un ethnologue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l apple claude lévi-strauss de la cage
d'escalier
si on lui avait laissé le temps il y
aurait pas pondu tristes tropiques mais
facétieux pachtoune
façon qu'on cesse les stigmatisations ça
c'est le grand mot la stigmatisation
armstrong et le stigmatiser de la
semaine
alors c'est peut-être pas un exemple
pour les jeunes qui font du vélo mais
quel exemple pour les toxicomanes qui
n'en font pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà un homme qui prouve qu'on peut
être toxique eau gagner de l'argent
avoir une vie normale des enfants faire
du sport enfin
franchement à part lors des descentes de
police est quand même rare de voir un
consommateur de crack faire du jogging
c'est moi j'ai vu des toxicos en plus
mauvais état franchement armstrong pour
un drogué tu mets dans une salle de
shoot tu le confond avec le médecin de
garde
sinon ah oui les bonnes nouvelles de la
semaine kerviel de rembourser 4,9
milliards
ici c'est facile lui la seule solution
c'est le mariage gay
à part ce mac et avec bernard arnault je
vois pas trop de solution pour lui
et puis des trucs plus ça c'est assez un
peu de respect ça c'est un peu compliqué
à 180 décès du doyen des rescapés
d'auschwitz
c'est avec ce genre d'infos que tu te
rends compte que finalement faire du
sport est bouffé bio ça sert à rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à rabastens
[Musique]
ah oui j'ai oublié économiquement la
folie fiscale continue et maintenant on
va taxer les boissons énergisantes
s'écoule vu la mollesse du gouvernement
c'est dans l'ordre des choses reste plus
qu à défiscaliser la verveine
alors pas mal d'années et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez
vous je m'étais 1 pouces bleus